into all the data that will be shared
transparently through the fda reviews
with its advisory committee
of the pfizer vaccine as mr secretary
said
on december 10th and of the modern
vaccine
more or less a week later and hopefully
these vaccines will become
available the astrazeneca face streets
right had also more
intriguing data in that a certain
particular schedule
of immunization in terms of dosage has
yielded an efficacy that was somewhat
less
62 percent and when the two combined
together uh an average of about 70
protection has been achieved these
observations
and data were generated from clinical
trials run in the uk
and in brazil we have a phase three
trial running here in the us
it has already recruited more than 11
000 subjects into it
unfortunately the pandemic in the u.s is
progressing
so fast that it is very likely that this
trial
not long from now may have enough
evidence generated within it
to assess the efficacy of the vaccines
as
administered here we are of course also
reviewing in-depth
with the astrazeneca and oxford teams uh
all the specifics of the data generated
to understand
what difference there is between the
schedule that gives a 62 percent
efficacy and one that gives 90 percent
efficacy
on the therapeutic side i'd like to also
add one element of information to the
information that mr secretary gave which
is
an important one i think in the sense
that merck
the large u.s pharmaceutical company has
acquired
a small biotech company called onco
immune that we have identified about
seven eight weeks ago as holding
data with a particular program in their
portfolio
that are really impressive in that in
in the interim analysis of their phase 3
trial that was ongoing
they had over 50 percent relative
reduction
in the risk of mortality in patients
that had severe
hospitalized but not yet intubated
condition with covet 19.
this acquisition is something that we
have participated to
make happen in connecting the company
the small company that has
10 10 people working in it with merck as
a mean to help accelerate
uh the development of this therapeutic
important therapeutic for
u.s patients and finally the last point
i'd like to make
is to invite as many volunteers as
possible to please
come and participate into the vaccine
trials
if you are healthy and particularly
if you correspond to the at risk
populations over the age of 65
with comorbidities or if you
are part of the rich diversity
of populations in the united states it
is through your generous participation
in clinical trials that we are able to
generate and understand the performance
of our vaccines
and help us make them available faster
and better
for all of you thank you and pass on now
to general purna for
a brief update thanks dr slowly and of
course mr secretary thanks for the
opportunity to be a part of this
so uh good morning everybody um i want
to say thanks for
participation uh as both my secretary
and dr salawi said
it's really just important that we're
able to get the message out
on a routine basis so thank you for
that last week i talked about our
distribution
and our method just as a recap you know
we chose a whole of america approach
in distribution for two reasons
one we wanted the experts who know how
to do this
to help us plan and be a part of it to
ensure that we had the right capability
and capacity
so from pfizer moderna mckesson trucking
through fedex ups down to the pharmacies
such as cvs and walgreens
and many others the intent was to
integrate
synchronize and capitalize on
known uh professionals who know how to
execute this
our cornerstone is the cdc these experts
know how to distribute
vaccines they do it annually and we were
able to take all their lessons learned
over the years
and apply them into the plan
second reason we chose this whole of
america approach
is we wanted the american people to have
confidence
in the process not to be
afraid of or enamored by all the
grandiose schemes
but yet just know that the common names
of america
are distributing the vaccine to them
and that when they have the vaccine
administered it'll be in locations that
they're comfortable with
local hospitals doctors offices local
pharmacies such as cvs and walgreens
or private pharmacies supporting rural
areas
areas so again it was about making sure
we had the capability and capacity
and two giving the american people the
confidence
uh that the vaccine will be delivered on
a timely and routine manner
so today uh with that said i'd like to
talk about three things
one our allocation strategy to
uh the pfizer testing that they've been
doing
in moving their product around the
nation in their containers
and then three how are we actually
managing ultra cold storage
i think three points a highlight that
would help you
see the specificity of the things we're
doing
so first allocation numbers went to the
64 jurisdictions and five federal
agencies last friday
in fact that the we hit the button at uh
11 35
pm or 23 35 military time
and that information went out to all the
jurisdictions
and five agencies through tiberius each
received their allocation of the vaccine
so that they
can plan and figure out where they want
the vaccine to be
distributed to as a reminder we are
able to distribute the vaccine to any
location
in any jurisdiction that has been
enrolled
as a provider we are not constrained by
numbers
it could be one it could be a thousand
or beyond
as long as they are a enrolled provider
uh and the state approves them and they
have the minimum requirement of the
vaccine which is 975 doses by pfizer
and 100 doses by moderna we collectively
with this whole of america approach can
deliver
anywhere in america to that end
second we have maintained a minimum
safety stock but i need to assess the
initial distribution of the vaccine
to ensure that everybody understands the
process
understands the clarity of requirements
for
ultra cold storage and understands
uh how to utilize and administer the
vaccine
but once we are confident that the the
jurisdictions are confident
then we will release the safety stock to
ensure
maximum use in the country we have
provided and we are working with each of
the administration
or jurisdictions right now methods plan
and then figure out allocation within
the states
through the system we call tiberius
we've been working with the
jurisdictions for quite some time now
uh partnered at the cdc level on how to
run
scenarios to actually determine where
they put their allocation of vaccine
to the best advantage in following fda
eua guidance as well as cdc
asip guidance this way that leadership
of the state
has the maximum capability and capacity
to plan
look through different scenarios and
then make a final decision to best
impact the people of the united states
really powerful system
to help us lead our way through
execution
and not react we will be
sending um after we send the initial
push of the vaccine
here a pendant eua then we'll be on a
straight
steady drum beat of sending allocations
to the jurisdictions
every week right we'll allocate vaccines
jurisdictions will be allowed to uh go
in
24 7 and order and distribute the
vaccine to
where they want it and then the
following day
we'll be able to get it to the locations
that they designate
really hard work uh great collaboration
with both hhs department of defense
and industry to get this right but i'm
very
very confident that we have a solid plan
and that we have the ability to to
observe
watch monitor adjust uh to meet the
requirements
um as has been specified uh through the
through the states so very difficult
challenge
we're working on this constantly we work
rehearsals
of different um scenarios to make sure
we're capturing all the nuances of the
delivery
but each and every week we get stronger
it's it's not lost to anybody listening
we're one week closer to distributing
the vaccine
we're one week closer to refining to the
exactness that we need
to have to do this and i'm very
confident in that process
so the second thing i'd like to talk to
you about is the pfizer-initiated test
really remarkable you know we do this
all the time
in the department of defense it's one of
our strengths we know how to plan we
know how to rehearse
i was equally excited to watch pfizer
and moderna
go through similar processes to make
sure that their product is right
to begin with but most importantly we
can get it where it needs to be
when it's time uh to get it out to the
american people
pfizer is really implementing a very
aggressive
uh approach to figuring out how to get
their
product out to the administration sites
as designated by the states
they're running dry rehearsals as we
like to call it in dod this way they run
through the actual process
of registering product through a
jurisdiction
then they deliver the product then they
walk the administration
sites through the actual opening
and how do they manage the product out
of the container
really powerful to watch and
see people learning pfizer is capturing
lessons learned and they're putting it
in training product
fact sheets as well as creating youtube
like videos
for everybody to observe and monitor
we started small at four locations we
recently expanded to 10 locations
we are going to go to the remaining 54
locations
uh to ensure that everybody has an
understanding of this
uh what we have found in general is
initial hesitation
once the product is received but as
pfizer
has walked the administration sites
through the execution
we see growing confidence in everybody
that's using it
and that has been the story throughout
every
uh rehearsal so far again we have to
walk through
everybody to make sure everybody's
confident in it
but i think i personally have gone
process
i've managed i've actually put my hands
in the box
i've pulled trade out i've watched and
i've timed
myself in execution it is a
very very doable process our
professionals
both medical at the medical level and
then
at the pharmacy level are very well
versed on how to do this
it is not the first time and i feel the
confidence in the reinforcement through
our rehearsals
uh our training products and then actual
execution will create
a steady level of confidence for the
final
full and complete administration of the
vaccine so well done by pfizer
and moderna uh getting ready to do
similar uh acts accordingly
so uh last uh but not least it is about
the ultracold storage
uh of the vaccine we've all heard pfizer
vaccine has a requirement of
80 minus 80 degrees right at ultra
cold storage this freezer is
important but not to a limiting
limiting end in other words pfizer has
created a container
which is augmented with dry ice that
maintains the vaccine
at the appropriate level in doing so
they've enabled the extension of vaccine
storage at the right to maintain the
right stability for up to 20 days
uh really a tremendous effort as i just
described
in the training that they're doing to
ensure that the vaccine
is available and stable and appropriate
for administration
and we feel confident that if states
plan to the right dosage at the right
locations
that the drum beat the cadence the
administration of vaccine
to the minimum amount which is 975 doses
is very doable within the 20 days
clearly we have to have a plan clearly
we have to hold ourselves accountable
to administering that but it is a plan
that can be done
and we feel confident in talking with
the jurisdictions that they've worked
through
these details to ensure that the vaccine
is used
appropriately and without any waste
which is the biggest important factor
for us so
a challenge yes but it should not
hold us back from administering a very
good vaccine to the american people
moderna is a different case they're at
minus 20 degrees
minus 20 degrees is equivalent to a
normal
kitchen refrigerator freezer or a
freezer that is most commonly found
in most pharmacies etc it has greater
stability and that it can go in
refrigeration
for all third days yes so it becomes
a vaccine that its administration
becomes
easier to do and it will enable us to
get to many
places throughout the country as we've
talked about before
from inner city out to rural america it
produces an advantage
to that end but i will tell you that i
believe the jurisdictions are ready
they've been well informed on the
information of both vaccines
both requirements for coal chain storage
they have added capability and capacity
as required
they have trained people to administer
it they have contacted pharmacies for
support like walgreens and cvs
to help them and we are well on our way
to successfully administering
both vaccines to the american people in
the near future
so mr secretary that concludes my
comments thank you general
and at this point we'll take questions
from the media
question as a reminder this call is
recorded
if you would like to ask a question
please press star 1 from your phone
unmute your line and speak your name
clearly when prompted
your name is needed to introduce the
question
please limit to one question so we can
try to address all questions today
if you would like to withdraw your
question please press star
too again if you would like to ask a
question please press star one
one moment please as we wait for any
questions our first question
will come from helen branswell
helen your line is open thanks very much
um this is probably a dumb question but
can you talk us through the logistics of
how this will work um how many
you know a hospital didn't say uh reno
gets uh uh 995 doses of the
pfizer vaccine are they meant to
then try to vaccinate 995 healthcare
workers as quickly as they can
or are they supposed to reserve help of
that
trash so that they can give that group
of people
their second vaccine later
it's not how does it how can they be
assured that they're
going to be in the right place in the
line to get the second dose when those
people need their second dose
okay so uh what what we're working with
is the state to really work their micro
plans
on the final distribution and that's
what they're actually
putting into place over the next two
weeks in preparation for eua
and they're specified in there they've
identified
a amounts of providers
providers can be everywhere from local
hospitals
doctors offices pharmacies etc
as long as they're enrolled we can
distribute to them in their plans
and with their identified priorities
they will specify
how they want to administer the vaccine
so in your example
let's say one tray from pfizer vaccine
goes to a hospital
it has 970 doses
in the tray vials can be taken
out of the tray right every single day
and brought down to room temperature for
administered
it's not a requirement to do all
975 in one day or one week
they have as i talked about up to 20
days
to really administer those 975 doses
uh to ensure that they can get the right
people
in the right places at the right time
currently
right now our plan is to initially
distribute
the first those vaccines to the states
and then
on a second delivery at 21 days for
pfizer
and 28 days for moderna the states will
receive
the vaccine for the second dose
there is methods from a
very simple here's your card come back
on this day for your second dose to very
elaborate
automated plans at both the state and
national level
to ensure reminders are sent
and the vaccine is available for the
persons
we are continually to assess the
manufacturing of the vaccine
uh and we think that once we have a
really steady
confident cadence in manufacturing in
the very near future
there's potential to just
vaccinate at maximum allocation because
we have confidence that the second dose
will be available
accordingly we're just the starting this
way
initially to ensure that everybody
understands the process
uh and we can be accounted for thank you
next question please
the next question is from zach brennan
politico
hi thanks for taking the question so can
you talk a little bit about the timing
with the asip recommendation after a
possible eua
will they be able to adjust where the
first round of doses will go
based on the asic recommendations even
if you're shipping
you know within 24 hours after the eua
yep so zach i think it's important to
understand the nature of
acip's role this is for for other
members of the media this is the
advisory committee on immunization
practices which is an advisory committee
set up under statute that's used by cdc
connected especially
usually the vaccine for children's
program
the acip has of course a very important
role in that
uh when they make a recommendation
for a group to be vaccinated uh that
they say
essentially that the efficacy outweighs
safety risk for vaccination and they
recommend vaccination
that triggers various reimbursement
mechanisms in our system
once there's an acip recommendation as
we have with the national academies of
science we've worked with the
advisory committee on immunization
practices uh to in addition to their
statutory
obligation on that binary recommendation
to vaccinate uh we've also sought any
insight input
etc around when dealing with a scarce
quantity vaccine
which groups which which uh which
cohorts to prioritize
at the end of the day uh that is a
decision though of the us government to
make
which is where to recommend the
prioritization
and in the final say it will be our
nation's
governors in implementing the
distribution plans
to tell us as general purna has
repeatedly said
where to ship and they will decide whom
the vaccine is given to
uh we hope that our recommendations will
carry
weight with them but at the end of the
day they will make that decision and so
we are not dependent on any delay for
acip in terms of
helping to advise states on that
prioritization we received some
information just yesterday from acip we
had received the national academy's
input
previously which is still going through
some public comment with them
but we will work uh we are working
expeditiously
to formulate our recommended
prioritization
uh for vaccine distribution based on
where we can
secure the maximum effect under whatever
the current epidemiological
circumstances are
in the united states at that time thank
you
next question please
the next question is from john cohn john
your line is open
thanks so much um the company has been
less than transparent about how the
half dose occurred and i'm wondering
whether they explain
to you what happened and also whether
you have plans to switch to half dose
as the prime for the astrazeneca oxford
yes so we we have been made aware
of the what's called now the half dose
at the time it has happened
this was a change
in the way the quantity of vaccine
the amount of vaccine put in a vial
was tested and
when they when they realized that there
was an error
or a change in the approach and the
technique used
uh they corrected it and in in in the
meantime about 3 000 subjects were
recruited half of them in the placebo
and half of them in the vaccine group
and that's the cohort that has shown 90
efficacy
that's i would say the fact in terms of
what has been
inputted into the vaccines what we are
now looking to analyze
is what immune response has been induced
in those who have
received the health dose and the full
dose versus those that have received
twice the full dose
and understand whether there are
differences in the immune response
induced
you should also know that there are also
differences
in the age brackets present in the
cohorts in that the first cohorts that
received
the half dose and full dose followed by
a full dose had a cap on the age at the
age of 55
when there are older people included in
the
city that received full dose and full
dose so there are a number of variables
that we need to understand and what what
has been the role of each one of them
in achieving the difference
in in efficacy once we understand
then we'll make a decision as to
whether to for instance uh modify in
part
the ongoing phase three trial here and
introduce
for instance half those and full dose or
any otherwise that we want it to be
based on data and science because we
understand the input but we don't
understand the consequences of the input
i should just say for completeness
scientifically that the 90
fxe group and the 62 efficacy group
are overlapping statistically so it is
still possible
that that difference is is is a random
difference
it's unlikely but it's still possible
it's a random difference
we need to understand what's behind it
scientifically thank you
next question
the next question is from carl o'donnell
carl your line is open
hi this is carl o'donnell from reuters
um you mentioned that you had given
some guidance to the uh the states in
terms of the
the general size of the initial
allocation of vaccine that they're going
to get to help them prepare
do you have a national figure at this
point for the amount of
vaccine you know that will be
distributed overall to the different uh
states and jurisdictions um and what
what is that figure and are you
confident that we'll still
get to the 40 million figure overall by
the end of the year
so yes i do feel confident that we're
going to get to
close as close as we can to 40 million
at the end of the year i mean snap the
chalk line what
exactly comes off we'll know at the end
but i do feel confident and we've
planned
scenarios to that end and we've worked
with the jurisdictions
for the total amount through december
the initial
amount uh as we were speculating
on when eu would a would come out
because we're not involved in that
process
literally on the white board we're
trying to figure out when that decision
might be made
i finally made the decision friday night
late friday night
to snap the chalk line so states could
prioritize
based on amount that amount that we
allocated to the country was 6.4 million
doses of vaccine uh and then
what will happen if uh if there's more
available
after the initial push then it will go
out in the following
weekly cadences of distribution
accordingly
but yes 40 million by the end of the
year
next question please
next question is dan bergano buzzfeed
news
thanks very much uh i'm wondering if you
have any concern that
uh the general population will be
disappointed uh when they figure out the
prioritization is going on that is going
to healthcare workers and
uh nursing homes that sort of thing and
not sort of the general
public until it sounds like months from
now months have been discussed like
april the june thereabouts
if you had any guidance on that as well
that would be great thanks very much
well dan we've been very transparent
throughout
uh for the american people and for you
all about
the timelines as we best understand them
at each step of the way
and potential prioritized groups of
course
we have not announced recommended
prioritization we've talked about some
core groups that make some fairly
obvious sense especially in light of the
national academy's
input and the advisory committee on
immunization practices focus
those of course are those in nursing
homes as you mentioned
uh our most vulnerable citizens our
health care workers who are on the front
lines our first responders those are
some of the
the broad groups we've talked about and
we focused and we've said
that we expect by the end of december to
have enough vaccine to vaccinate those
who are most vulnerable
just by way of sizing and scaling that
by the end of january we think we would
have enough to vaccinate our senior
citizens as well as our
health care workers and first responders
and then as the general is talked about
progressively week after week
just more vaccine keeps coming off of
the production gets quality controlled
and released
into the system additional prioritized
groups
or eventually just general vaccination
availability
to the point that in the second quarter
of next year we believe we'd have enough
vaccine
from all sources to be able to make that
so that anyone who wanted to get a
vaccine in the united states would be
able to get that
but that's a progression a constant
progression and
and so we've been very clear for months
really about about that sequence and
that's that's the best we can do is just
to use forums like these and others
uh to educate in that regard
we have time for three more questions
the next question comes from tom howe
washington times hi uh thanks for doing
the call
this question is probably for the
secretary uh earlier in the year there
were some polls
that showed um some people were leery of
taking a vaccine so that was tied to
campaign timelines now that the election
is over and now that some
data's coming in that shows these shots
are quite effective how confident are
you that people
will be eager to go take up the vaccine
and what are you doing to ensure um to
alleviate any skepticism especially
among minority populations thank you
yeah thank you very much tom excellent
question uh you're right
we saw ever increasing uh numbers of
potential vaccine hesitancy
in previous months unfortunately there
was a lot of rhetoric out there that was
not helpful
in terms of inspiring confidence in the
process the president and i
have been clear that politics would play
no role
in the development the manufacture the
distribution or approval
of a vaccine uh i think the proof is in
the pudding there
uh that we now that that we have all of
these various
checks on independence in the system
i've talked about five
separate checks the data and safety
monitoring board
that determines even if the drug company
gets to see data the drug companies own
ethical checks
where they determine if they even find
the data to meet their ethical standards
to submit for approval
the fact that the fda has laid out both
final biologic license as well as eua
guidance
on what standards they would hold a
vaccine applicant
to the fact that the fda would hold a
public advisory process with their
vaccine advisory committee
that is an independent transparent
public process they've already announced
on friday
that december 10th will be the date for
the pfizer advisory committee
and then finally the fact that fda
career scientists career leaders
will make the ultimate call on whether a
vaccine meets fda's data
scientific evidentiary and legal
standards for authorization or eventual
approval
uh we have seen since the pfizer and
moderna data have come out with such
exceptional results
and of course with the passing of the
election we have seen in public polling
increases in vaccine acceptance uh among
the
among people uh we obviously remain
concerned especially in various
underserved communities
about any issues of vaccine hesitancy
the cdc
our assist sector for public affairs as
well as
all of our public health leaders are
working on a public service announcement
campaign
that would work to educate the broad
population regarding
the need to be vaccinated the safety of
the vaccine the efficacy of the vaccine
the importance of getting vaccinated if
you're in one of the target prioritized
groups
and we'll just keep we'll keep doing
that and i think progressively
as more and more people get vaccinated
over time to prioritize groups moving
forward eventually to general
vaccination
hopefully there's a positive experience
for individuals
and that by word of mouth in addition of
course to all of the education efforts
we continue to reduce vaccine hesitancy
and continue to increase support among
people to get vaccinated
i've told you i certainly uh
will will have complete confidence in
the process
and i will get myself vaccinated as soon
as i will be allowed to be vaccinated to
demonstrate to the american people
my complete confidence in the
independence and integrity
of the process and the quality of any
vaccine that
i would make available to the american
people
next question the next question is from
andrew dunn
business insider andrea you may begin
thank you i was wondering what do you
see as the
to put it simply the ultimate
responsibility of state
in the distribution process um can you
go over clearly what jurisdictional
public health leaders will need to do
as part of the campaign and have you
heard from many states of regions about
a need for additional funding to
actually make that happen at the state
level
yeah thanks i'll i'll start in the last
general purna to add to it
uh so this is obviously as we talked
about in our last call
this is there are two types of
partnerships here that are involved the
first is the public-private partnership
of what we're trying to do to really
leverage these systems around vaccine
distribution in the united states that
are well rehearsed
and that work we want to make the
experience for people
as close to the flu vaccination
experience as possible in terms of
meeting them where they
are the second is a federal state
partnership very tight linkage between
us
we have gotten the vaccine we are paying
for the vaccine
we are paying for the distribution of
the vaccine we have secured the kits
that go with vaccination that's the
needles the syringes the diluent the
last mile dry ice etc
to marry that up with the vaccine
we have the data systems for
distributing the vaccine as well as for
accounting for
the immunization of individuals the
tracking of individuals to ensure they
get a second dose of the same vaccine
what is the role of the states of course
the governors
will determine distribution within their
states prioritization within their
states where to ship to as the general
has said
we can ship to one site or a thousand
sites in a state depending on the
governor as long as they're enrolled in
the system and the governor tells us
uh what he or she would like us to do
that's one tell us as almost an air
traffic controller
where would you like us to send or have
sent
the product the second is ensure your
data systems
are working with hours and that you've
signed data use agreements to ensure
the trans the ability of coordination of
information
across the united states so that if
somebody gets vaccinated with the first
dose in new york
and they then go down to florida for the
rest of the winter they can get their
second dose in florida and if it was
pfizer it remains fizer it was moderna
it remains moderna these states will
obviously
if there are additional areas that they
would like to ensure distribution to be
on the normal traditional mechanisms
that we've worked on
hospitals chain drug stores community
pharmacies
community health centers public health
departments
if governors feel there's a need for
customized other approaches
they are fully at liberty to set those
up
um that is that is that is part of them
being in the driver's seat
on that localized micro distribution
planning
we've put out 340 million dollars for
flu and
and covid 19 vaccination to date
another 140 million is going out in
december uh
money should not be the barrier to
effective efficient distribution of the
product
working with the state but it is
important to remember
just how much of this entire process is
already federally funded and federally
supported
in partnership with the states general
mr secretary i
am 100 agreement in everything you said
and have nothing to add
thank you general uh one last question i
believe michael
thank you the next question is from
jared hopkins jared your line is open
thanks uh jared hopkins from the wall
street journal uh regarding allocation
i previously the cdc said that besides
population
local spread of covid was going to be a
factor for determining
for each state so can you explain sort
of how you guys
decided on each state's individual
allocations within that
6 million that that you mentioned
earlier is it based on infection rates
from friday or
or something else yeah so so jared um
you know given the national spread of
the disease
at this point and unfortunately for the
foreseeable future
working and seeking consultation with
the governors we asked the governors for
input on allocation methodology
we didn't receive feedback from many but
the feedback we did get was supportive
of what we proposed
which was to keep this simple and on the
initial allocations to follow a per
capita over the age of 18 population
based
uh formula for for trying for
distributing the vaccine
we wanted to keep this simple first
because we're seeing effectively
nationwide spread and susceptibility to
the disease
uh but also once we pass through
these initial tranches where we're in
much more of a scarcity situation
we're eventually going to get to the
point where it would need to be per
capita and so instead of having multiple
methodologies
we thought it best to keep it simple the
governor supported that from the
feedback that we received so that was
the approach we took correct correct
exactly right mr secretary um so we just
we thought that would be the fairest
approach
the the most consistent um i want to
thank you all for this we're going to
keep doing
this weekly or as much as needed we want
to make sure that you're getting your
questions answered that we're being
transparent about our
our operation warp speed work on
therapeutics on vaccines on distribution
practices
i was not asked about this but i do want
to let you know
that consistent with the gsa
administrator's ascertainment yesterday
uh last night our top career official
rear admiral schwartz who has been
leading our
transition planning efforts was last
night
in communication with the biden
transition team
uh we are immediately getting them all
of the pre-prepared
transition briefing materials uh we will
ensure
coordinated briefings with them to
ensure they're getting whatever
information that they feel they need
that's consistent with statute and
past practice i have reiterated i've
said
as i've said publicly to you all i
reiterated to admiral schwartz
my firm commitment that transition
planning and execution will be
professional cooperative and
collaborative
uh in the best spirit of looking out for
the health and well-being of the
american people
and in particular saving lives through
this covid19 pandemic
i want to say again just thanks to the
support unwavering
and constant and personal support that
this team has had from president trump
from the beginning
to create operation warp speed to give
us the full funding of resources
and the independence to act with speed
and agility
we now have phase three data
on three vaccines three more vaccines
in active study five therapeutics
now are authorized or approved by the
fda
to help people suffering from covid
so much is already here so much
is on the way as i say hope and help
are on the way but that also means we're
bridging right now
we're bridging to when we have these
vaccines that general purna is going to
ensure are getting out there to our most
vulnerable and to our health care
workers and our first responders and
eventually
the broad american population it means
we need to bridge through our individual
behaviors
we want to make sure that everybody can
get to the day of experiencing
the benefits of the work that that team
is delivering
and that means wash your hands watch
your distance
wear your face coverings when you can't
watch your distance
stay out of settings where you can't do
those things
be especially mindful of indoor
gatherings
especially those where you might let
your guard down like household
gatherings
overcrowded indoor restaurants indoor
bars
especially now as we approach
thanksgiving
i ask all americans please be on guard
take care of yourselves be careful
because there is such
a bright day ahead with what this team
is delivering on vaccines and
therapeutics
we want to make sure that everybody is
here
for next year's thanksgiving so thank
you all very much and members of the
media thank you for helping us
in our efforts to ensure the american
people go on this journey with us
thank you thank you all you can send any
follow-up questions to our press office
at media
hhs.gov thank you all for joining
today's briefing
[Music]
you